45 witnesses as you know testified
during more than three weeks
of derrick shovin's trial one witness
for the prosecution was a bystander his
name is charles mcmillan
he broke down in court after watching
footage of george floyd's deadly
encounter with
police charles mcmillan joins us now for
an exclusive interview he's joined by
with his attorney his attorney's name is
will walker we welcome you both
gentlemen
mr mcmillan i want to start with you
because we all remember you very well
you were standing on the sidelines you
were walking there by with your shower
shoes
watching watching what was unfolding and
i was wondering did you know george
floyd no ma'am i didn't you didn't know
him
my man what was your reaction yesterday
when you got the news about the verdict
i didn't have a reaction yesterday
because it didn't
no ma'am i mean that one because i knew
they had to
they had to charge him yesterday
either they charged him or we wouldn't
be sitting here today
because of the crime so it wasn't some
shock to me
did you think the verdict would would
did you think that he would be convicted
on all three counts
no so were you surprised when you heard
you were surprised yes ma'am and that's
what i want to know so when you heard
that
the verdict was that he was found guilty
on all three counts
what did you think
i didn't think i kept doing what i was
doing you did where were you when you
got the news i was at work
you were at work yes and how did you
hear
it was somebody came i work at a car
wash uh-huh and somebody came through it
was telling me
and they said man you really did it and
i go dear well they go they found the
guildhall church
how how have you been affected by what
you saw that day
i've been affected very emotionally yeah
a very emotion i'm still the motion
behind what i watch happen with george
no we saw you when you broke down on the
stand
i think everybody's hearts opened up to
you because it was clear listen it was
very difficult for all of us to watch
but i was
i think many people were touched by you
where did that emotion come from that
particular day
it's come from me losing my mom prior to
this
what happened with george and hear
george cry out for his mom
yes and mama couldn't help him it made
me
just helpless because i don't have a mom
either yeah
and that's what broke me was mama i
think that broke all of us
yes what did you think was happening as
you were watching that unfold with
george floyd what did you think was
going on
because you said you just walked by and
you happened to see it
what i thought was going to happen is
what did happen
when i seen the interaction with george
with the police i know something bad
was going to be an outcoming of this and
that's why you started screaming to him
you can't win you can't win
yes that's why because i knew he wasn't
going to be able to win
and i knew that why did you know that mr
mcmillan because i've had interact with
the police myself
and once they get the cuffs on you you
got to really
have something good to say or nothing at
all
[Music]
you seem to me to be trying to in some
way comfort george floyd at a very
difficult time
because you could tell he was in great
distress yes it seemed like you were
trying to help him yourself
yes ma'am i was because one thing about
me i'm a people person
yes we could tell when i see something
happen that i see where it's going to
call somebody
i want to try to de-excellate that
situation
and that's why i was so close to the
police because i want them to hear me
that i'm trying to help this man do not
hurt this man
did you realize as you were standing
there that he had died at that time or
did you find out later
when i was standing up i still didn't
watch everything yeah i never left your
side yeah
just like a brother just like a brother
i'm not gonna leave my brother standing
and laying there so i stayed there and
watched him and what do you
what do you hope will happen now
now that the verdict has come and he's
been this police officer has been
convicted on all three counts
what are what are you hoping that this
will mean
for the police department for the
community
in my eyes i don't think it's going to
mean
too much anything everybody got to work
on change
yes the whole world got to work on
change
bonnie george sending a message for
change
and if we don't do it together nothing's
gonna never happen all right
uh mr walker uh we're glad you're here i
didn't know you were coming today
and uh you didn't either can i ask why
does mr mcmillan need an attorney for
the first pla in the first place
well initially there were concerns that
my client had
of whether or not what implications
might arise from him
offering testimony against police okay
there were safety considerations we
tried to work with the county attorney's
office and the attorney general's office
on these issues
okay um fortunately mr mcmillan stood up
for the community
you did stand up for the community and
we're very proud of that yeah
we are very proud of that it seems like
you're in good hands with mr
walker and we thank you for your time
you look very dapper this morning sir
thank you
thank you so much